[Music]
we're going to kick this off and go to
indianapolis with rebecca hey rebecca
how are you
good how are you good how can john and i
help today can you hear me yeah yeah
you're great what's going on
um so i graduated in 2019 with a hundred
thousand dollars in debt 36 of that was
my name and the rest was in my dad's
name as a consolidated parent plus loan
um and then he wants me to pay it back
but i'm not sure what to do here because
when i went to college i actually had a
full ride to one school but my parents
wanted me to go to the same school that
they did
i didn't have money for school and my
dad just said we'd figure it out with
loans and that he would sign all the
paperwork and do all the details and he
would just call me every semester to
fill out the paperwork and get it signed
and we would figure out later how to pay
it back he said initially that i would
pay for textbooks and tuition and that
he would take care of the grooming
whether that was the dorm or renting an
apartment
but
you know i found out later that he used
the rent
to pay for the apartment with the parent
plus ones so when i graduated he said
that i'd pay two thirds of the seventy
three thousand dollar parent plus loan
but now he's changing the turn to half
and half and now it's kind of just we'll
both work towards it until we get it
paid off but he hasn't paid a penny
throughout this whole entire interest
rate deferment and i've been kicking my
butt off to get my own loans paid off so
good for you
so you you guys fell prey to
the three worst words in the english
language which is figured out or four
we'll figure it out
um which is mean let's just punt this
hard decision way down the road and it
just gets more complex and more messy
the further along we go
um
i
i'm torn on this christy so hop in here
i part of me says
your original agreement was
you got into a school mom and dad say we
don't want you to go there once you go
to our school we'll cover it we'll take
care of it we'll figure it out in the
road but we're going to take care of
this and then you found out take care of
it man they took out a loan in your name
and
now you're going to be on the hook for
it
um the other part of me says
i mean
you're i mean your name's on the loan at
the end of the day you're going to lose
your dad over this deal and you may end
up having to pay this back anyway
um so my off top my head christie i love
to hear what you say my off top my head
i'd love you guys to sit down you sit
down with a spreadsheet or a piece of
paper and a pen
across the table from your dad and said
the days of we'll just figure it out are
over here is the dollar amount that i
slash we owe
here's what you told me
and we need to come away from this with
a plan and we're both going to sign this
piece of paper and this is going to be
hard for you but you are having to be
the adult because you're being dragged
around by a child masquerading as an
adult does that make sense
yeah well so the 36 000 alone is just in
my name and then he has 73 000 that is
just his name is that seventy three
thousand okay just in the parent plus
you're right so is that 73 was it school
expenses only
or did he use that for other things
i am not sure so when i calculated my
room and board and tuition and
everything there's an extra 25 000 that
i can't account for and i'm not sure
what it's for and he doesn't like to
talk about it yeah there's a lot of
unknowns here rebecca the the agreement
up front was unknown the agreement now
is unknown it's a moving target you feel
like you're not gonna be able to hit the
target and you can't because it's moving
i completely agree with john you sit
down have a conversation come up with a
new agreement you both agree on and then
whatever that is even if it's that you
pay all of it you'll feel peace just
knowing what you're working toward here
because right now it's a moving target
sit down and have a conversation
nail down the terms and i think you'll
feel better whatever that is